The last gasps of the Snyderverse, Battinson's
second outing, and the glorious return of the Man
of Steel. As DC turns to a new chapter, which of
these upcoming movies are you most excited to see?
For a moment, it really looked like Henry Cavill
was coming back for Man of Steel 2. After leaving
The Witcher and making a cameo appearance in Black
Adam, Cavill was all set to don the cape and get
back to fighting crime. However, after James Gunn
and Peter Safran took over the newly named DCU,
Man of Steel 2 was quickly scrapped and
Cavill was retired from the role of Superman.
So what's in store for Superman
in the all-new DC Universe? Well,
Gunn and Safran announced their initial
slate of DCU projects on January 31st,
2023, and the biggest film in
the works is Superman: Legacy.
"Next up is the big one, the
true beginning of the DCU."
Gunn wrote the film and Safran is hoping to
get him to direct — and it is, apparently,
not another superhero origin story. Safran said:
"It focuses on Superman balancing
his Kryptonian heritage with his
human upbringing. He is kindness in a world
that thinks of kindness as old-fashioned."
Casting remains unknown on Superman: Legacy, which
is scheduled to hit movie theaters on July 11th,
2025. We also know that it will kick
off the first chapter of the new DCU,
which Gunn and Safran have given
the name "Gods & Monsters."
Warner Bros. and DC Comics know they've got one
of the most lucrative franchises of all time
with Batman and his vast world of side characters,
villains, settings, and lore. To that end, Warner
has multiple Batman-based movies in the works that
are pretty much entirely separate from each other.
In addition to the Birds of Prey offshoot Black
Canary and Joker and its sequel, there's 2022's
The Batman, starring Robert Pattinson as a nascent
Dark Knight. The cast, and co-writer-director
Matt Reeves, did such a good job establishing
this new Batman world that Warner Bros. grew
keen on expanding it. The movie's $770 million
box office haul probably didn't hurt, either.
The expansion of Reeves' Bat-verse will
begin with the HBO series The Penguin,
with Colin Farrell reprising his titular role.
Meanwhile, Reeves is actively conceptualizing
The Batman Part II, which is set to be
released on October 3rd, 2025 — but it
won't be part of the DCU proper. Instead, Part
II will be labeled a DC Elseworlds project,
allowing it to exist in its own world,
far away from the rest of the DC Universe.
Henry Cavill's Superman might be consigned
to the history books, but that's not going
to stop DC from mining as much creative
potential out of Kal-El as they possibly can.
Aside from Gunn's own movie, the studio
is producing an Elseworlds project from
Ta-Nehisi Coates. Here's what we know
so far: Coates, known for his powerful
social journalism and comic book runs
with Black Panther and Captain America,
is penning the script. J.J. Abrams and Bad Robot
are attached to the film on the production side,
but Abrams isn't in the running to direct.
Instead, DC and Warner Bros. are looking for both
a Black director and a Black lead actor for the
film. Sadly, nobody has been confirmed just yet.
As far as the film's plot, The Hollywood
Reporter has claimed that it might be
a "20th-century period piece," and
that Coates' version of Superman is
"a Kal-El in the vein of the original
Superman comics." Obviously, though,
these are early days, and recent comments
made by Gunn suggested that DC has yet to
see a finished script from Coates. For now,
you'll just have to keep your eyes on the sky.
Yes, it's finally happening: Kara Zor-El is set
for her big solo cinematic project. Supergirl:
Woman of Tomorrow was another movie announced by
Gunn and Safran in January 2023. Based on
the eponymous comic book run by Tom King,
Woman of Tomorrow will revolve around a
dark, space-based sci-fi revenge story.
"She watched everybody around
her perish in some terrible way,
so she is a much more jaded character."
King himself has been assisting Gunn in
developing this project, although we're
unsure who will play the darker, harder version
of the character. In the upcoming Flash movie,
Sasha Calle will appear as Supergirl, having
beat out hundreds of others for the role;
Gunn and Safran have yet to say whether or not
Calle would reprise the part in Woman of Tomorrow,
however, and a full reboot and a recast
certainly isn't out of the question.
Expect to hear more about Supergirl's
future in the coming weeks and months.
Today, WildStorm is an edgy imprint of DC
Comics, but it began life back in the 20th
century as an independent publisher,
best known for the superhero team-up
title Stormwatch. After a while, Stormwatch
morphed into the 1999 spinoff The Authority,
which was released after DC absorbed WildStorm
and incorporated its characters into its own
narrative canon. In 2023, James Gunn and
Peter Safran announced that a standalone
film based on the comic series would be one
of their first priorities as heads of the DCU.
Something of a rogue Justice League, the
Authority boasts a revolving membership
including such characters as the electric
Jenny Sparks, the liquid metal-based Engineer,
the magical Doctor, and the shadowy Midnighter.
During the reveal of the new slate, Gunn said:
"One of the things with the DCU is
it isn't just a story of heroes and
villains and not every movie and TV show is
going to be about good guy versus bad guy."
Apparently, that moral gray area will
be where the DCU Authority operates.
"There are people that are anti-heroes, and
there are people that are very questionable,
like the Authority, who basically
believe that you can't fix the world
in an easy manner, and they sort of
take things into their own hands."
In other words, if the Authority think they can
solve a problem, they'll do it — no matter how
violent, controversial, or devastating their
decisions. DC haven't announced a release date
for The Authority yet, but it's due to arrive
in the "Gods & Monsters" chapter of the new DCU.
As heads of the DCU, James Gunn and Peter
Safran are faced with the tricky proposition
of balancing multiple Batmans across different
narrative timelines. For example, filmmaker Todd
Phillips will continue to tell the story of Dark
Knight adjacent villain the Joker with Joker:
Folie à Deux, and Matt Reeves and Robert
Pattinson will release their sequel to The Batman.
Basically, there's a whole lot of Batmanning
going on in DC's future — but that's not all.
In January 2023, Gunn and Safran
announced yet another Batman project:
the official one — the Caped Crusader of record.
"Damian Wayne is my favorite Robin,
he's a little assassin who Batman
tries to get in line, so this is
the story of the two of them."
Based on Grant Morrison's comics series
of the same name, The Brave and the Bold
is part father-son drama, part superhero story,
and part crime extravaganza. Aside
from Damian Wayne, Safran has said
that we can expect to see other members of
Batman's family appear, telling the media:
"We feel like they've been left out of the
Batman stories in the theater for far too long."
Before he was appointed one
of the guardians of the DCU,
and before he brought the Guardians of
Galaxy to the big screen, James Gunn
was known for making humor-laced cult horror
movies. Decades later, it looks like Gunn is
going back to his roots. As part of the new
slate of DCU projects, Gunn announced that a
new Swamp Thing movie was in pre-production as
part of the studio's "Gods & Monsters" chapter.
In the 1980s, the DC Comics character headlined
two campy, low-budget films, and in 2019,
a Swamp Thing TV series lasted a
single season. The story concerns
kind-hearted botanist Dr. Alec Holland, who
is accidentally transformed into a massive
green swamp creature and decides to fight bad
guys. Gunn and cohort Peter Safran plan to go
back to square one with Swamp Thing and
explore the character's "dark origins."
So who will direct? Well,
these are still early days,
but Deadline has reported that Logan and
Indiana Jones director James Mangold is
in talks to helm the upcoming horror movie.
It doesn't have a release date yet either,
but horror fans can rest easy knowing that
Swamp Thing is right around the corner.
Having gained plenty of superhero experience
during the events of his 2019 solo vehicle,
young Billy Batson will be ready to
take on some new bad guys in the sequel,
Shazam! Fury of the Gods. And he'll have a little
help this time around. At the end of Shazam!,
Billy was able to defeat Doctor Sivana by
sharing his powers with his foster family,
transforming them into Shazam-like heroes who will
have a significant role to play in the sequel.
So who will Billy Batson and his foster
siblings face this time around? Well,
it looks like the Daughters of Atlas are
ticked off at the Shazamily for using the
power of the gods for their own crime-fighting
purposes. So Oscar-winner Helen Mirren, Lucy Liu,
and Rachel Zegler are coming to wreak havoc
as Hespera, Kalypso, and Athena. Based on the
trailers we've seen, it looks like once they get
their hands on a powerful weapon, they'll be able
to drain Shazam and his family of their superhero
powers, giving the goddesses a major edge.
Of course, the first Shazam! was a heck of
a lot of fun, but we all know that superhero
sequels tend to go darker. It stands to reason,
then, that young Billy is going to have some
growing up to do in Shazam! Fury of the Gods.
The sequel is released on March 17th, 2023.
The long-awaited solo film for the Flash has
been cooking since long before his DCEU debut.
A long list of writers and directors signed
onto and departed the project over the years,
and the movie's progress was only hindered by
Ezra Miller's bizarre crime spree across what
seemed like the entire United States.
Nevertheless, the movie is nearly here,
mostly thanks to the steady hand
of It director Andy Muschietti.
The Flash will take its narrative cues
from the iconic "Flashpoint" storyline,
bringing together various DC properties under
one mind-bogglingly complex multiverse. Expect
to see the return of Michael Keaton's Batman
and the debut of Sasha Calle's Supergirl in
the new movie — although rumors suggest that
previously filmed appearances from Ben Affleck,
Gal Gadot, and Jason Momoa may have
been cut from the final product.
"Oh, wow, they really just
vanish, huh? Oh, that's rude."
Recently, James Gunn has said that The Flash
is one of the greatest superhero movies ever
made and revealed that it will help reset the
entire DC universe. Interestingly, before Gunn
and Peter Safran took over the franchise, it was
reported that DC and Warner were already taking
steps toward a sequel. While Gunn has expressed
his desire to work with Muschietti in the future,
it's currently unknown what role, if any,
Barry Allen will play in the new regime.
The Blue Beetle moniker has been taken up
by a few different characters in the comics,
but the upcoming Blue Beetle film will focus
on the most recent: Jaime Reyes. In his comics,
Reyes discovers the Blue Beetle Scarab
entirely by accident and takes it home.
The artifact swiftly bonds with him and grants him
an extraterrestrial suit of armor and a slew of
powers to go with it. He's been part of several
different superhero groups in the DC universe,
so a Blue Beetle film could easily play
into several different IPs, depending
on what direction they choose to take the
character — and whether he has a future at all.
Xolo Mariduena will star as the titular superhero
in Blue Beetle, supported by Bruna Marquezine,
Belissa Escobedo, and Harvey Guillén.
Susan Sarandon will play Victoria Kord,
a character created specifically for the
film. Meanwhile, Raoul Max Trujillo [ will
be playing Carapax the Indestructible Man,
a villain housed in a mighty robotic body.
Gareth Dunnet-Alcocer, who wrote
the 2019 crime thriller Miss Bala,
will pen the screenplay for Blue Beetle,
while Angel Manuel Soto will direct,
following his work on 2020's Charm City Kings.
Blue Beetle hits theaters on August 18th, 2023.
Aquaman has been the butt of
pop culture jokes for decades,
owing to his seemingly lame power set.
Although comic book fans knew better,
the zeitgeist simply seemed to have it in for
Arthur Curry and his adventures in Atlantis.
"Did someone say cruise ship on the
ocean? Why didn't you invite me?"
"Oh, to tell the fish to get out
of the way? We figured it out."
"Nice one."
Meanwhile, Jason Momoa's first appearance as
the character in 2017's Justice League was
received well, if not rapturously, while the movie
itself underperformed severely at the box office.
But then a funny thing happened: James Wan's
Aquaman, in which Momoa reprised the role,
became a smash hit, raking in over a
billion dollars worldwide and becoming
the highest-grossing film in the DCEU by a
comfortable margin. It didn't take long for
Warner Bros. to determine that they had a hot
property on their hands, and in February 2019,
it was confirmed that a sequel was in the works.
Director James Wan will be returning for Aquaman
and the Lost Kingdom, as will Momoa and much
of the first movie's principal cast. Aquaman
co-screenwriter David Leslie Johnson-McGoldrick
also worked on the script for the sequel.
Interestingly, if one of Wan's Instagram posts is
anything to go by, the "Lost Kingdom" in the title
seems to refer to Necrus. This teleporting,
underwater city has occasionally clashed with
Aquaman and the denizens of Atlantis in the
past. Sadly, however, aside from a brief sneak
peek at DC Fandome, we've yet to see much more
from Aquaman's second adventure. Even weirder,
James Gunn recently suggested that The Lost
Kingdom will lead into his Superman movie
and the new DCU. Was he simply referring
to the chronology of the release slate,
or did he mean that their stories could be
related? Nobody knows — but we'll find out
for sure when the film splashes down
in theaters on December 25th, 2023.
Rather than adapting a well-known comic storyline,
the 2019 drama Joker was inspired by the long
history of Batman's greatest foe. Director and
co-writer Todd Phillips reimagined the character
as Arthur Fleck, a struggling comedian suffering
a full-on emotional breakdown. As Joker
earned multiple Academy Award nominations
and generated more than $1 billion in ticket
sales, a sequel was always bound to happen.
In fact, mere days after Joker opened to huge
box office numbers, Phillips began discussing
the future of DC Comics-based films with Warner
Bros. chairman Toby Emmerich. Rumors of a
Joker sequel emerged soon after. Details
were thin on the ground until June 2022,
when Phillips posted a photo of a script
cover page to his Instagram account,
bearing the title Joker: Folie à Deux.
Phillips also snapped a pic of Joaquin
Phoenix reading the screenplay, and we can
expect to see the star return to the screen
as part two of an Elseworlds series that
will exist outside of the main DC Universe.
"It's enough to make anyone crazy."
But Phoenix won't be alone here, as the one
and only Lady Gaga will be making her comic
book movie debut as Harley Quinn. Apparently,
she'll get to sing too, as the film is reportedly
going to be a musical set inside the imposing
Arkham Asylum. And, in case you're wondering,
Folie à deux is a form of shared psychosis
in which the delusions and hallucinations
experienced by one person are transferred to the
other. Sound familiar? Joker: Folie à Deux began
filming on December 10th, 2022; the release
date is currently set as October 4th, 2024.
The idea of a feature film based on the
near-unstoppable alien bounty hunter
Lobo has been kicking around before the DCU's
inception, with a Guy Ritchie-directed version
discussed as far back as 2009. The project
was revived as part of the DCEU slate in 2016,
with San Andreas and Rampage director Brad
Peyton set to helm from a script by Jason Fuchs,
who previously contributed to the screenplay
for Wonder Woman. It was rumored in early
2018 that none other than Michael Bay was
being eyed to take the reins on the movie,
and Fuchs was still reported
to be working on the script.
As became a theme with DC, however,
the television side of things quickly
threatened to intervene. The second season
of the Syfy series Krypton saw Irish actor
Emmett J. Scanlan take on the role of Lobo,
leading some observers to speculate that the
character's feature film prospects had dimmed. For
a while, there was no official word from Warner,
leaving fans to wonder whether a starring
vehicle for the ultra-violent baddie was
still in the cards. Things got more interesting
in November 2022 when James Gunn teased a possible
Lobo project in the DCU. Soon after, rumors
began to swirl that Aquaman star and devout
Lobo fan Jason Momoa could be interested
in playing the character in the future.
During their DCU reveal, James Gunn and
Peter Safran insisted that Momoa won't
be playing two characters at once — but they
didn't shoot down the rumors, either. Safran
said that Momoa has been very clear about how
much he loves Lobo, while Gunn simply said:
"We'll figure it out after Aquaman 2."